hier ist ein team diesem team das mich
für euch denkt wie denkst dir sehen
boss herbert und herzlich willkommen zum
heiler runde survival games vielleicht
auch zwei runden mit dabei ist mir
lieber nervtötender minecraft der let's
play der bruder kran zu dem kauf der
rechte kiste ich nämlich ganz links die
zweite von links
okay weil wir sind nicht gerechnet
allerdings fand ich hab zwei hosen
kommen direkt raus wir laufen angriffe
beinahe laufen ich dachte hier immer
hoch dass meine standorte kann gar nicht
anders
ich hab mir ich habe hier meinen stand
ist voll ist oder so wer im style zu was
zu sagen es nicht ob ich darüber nach
wie sie eigentlich müsste es heißen oder
nein
ja ja gut klar ja selbst spricht
eigentlich aus was recht bist du der
höhle drin in der schlossgasse ihren ich
bin hinter dir deine meinung wer denn
sonst kannst du dir eine junge stehen da
stehen als ich kann es gar nicht
behinderte als revo schon mal spricht
ihr ziel ich dass mich das mich ich bin
einfach nicht so gut und so kommt man
auf ein punkt den es geht
mit hits wie back ich habe übrigens ein
wenn wir die banalen hat herbert
werthmann dem
kommt wieder zurück zu vertrauen wieder
zurück button hatte der red darüber
nimmst du denn hier dem wasser ist halte
der keinen bäcker mit zwangsgeld sagt
okay ich hab ihm gegeben obwohl der
beste klub hatte und ich einfach in die
schlucht bewahrte hatte ich hätte ich
hätte ich bin ja noch mit der holz
achsen feierten alter habe ich ballerina
alter in seinem müssen wir jetzt durch
medien
okay ich hab dann gechillt hinter dem
hintermann hinter was denn
nein noch schalter warum war da noch
einer
egal ich finde wir holen ich habe das
meinen papa ich habe keine waffen mehr
als ich plötzlich ziemlich der hand zu
halten
naja leute ich würde sagen machen kurzen
card nachdem jetzt gesehen habt wie ich
meinen kaffee trinke also es ist
mitternacht nicht bedarf produzieren für
euch ich hoffe ihr wisst zu schätzen und
mit seinem wissens in der nächsten runde
mit dem games zudem greift er wieder das
wahr zu werden
bis gleich so dass wir wieder werden es
gerade in der zwischen pause von gucci
mainstream man kennt ist auf jeden fall
ein rapper der vollkommen verdreckt ist
ihr könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben was für musik ihr so hört es
wenn die echt mal interessant
ein schwert direkt sehr geil ich komme
auch daraus ich komme auch rausgehen ich
hoch auch wieder mit mir zu voll oder um
erweitert ihren sport hatte es gewagt
ich komm rüber zu hören ich habe nur
einen helm
zudem weisen schwert das heißt zwar bin
nicht ich bin verwundbar für höhle sagt
einfach das ist eine höhle keine ahnung
wieder schlug wie heißt du ich bin war
die blase irgendwas aber die verbände
unter die räder
vielleicht nehme ich an und ich bin der
dsv halte ich objektiv bin das wetter
war okay
das ist immer habe ich letztens in der
innerkrems folge schon gesagt es ist
immer so eine sache mit ihrem
aufzunehmen dass die ganze zeit nicken
muss und er muss sich an dicken hals
sonst wird der bewertende test abnahme
alte deshalb mal war schrecklich
wir hatten wir hatten eine abnahme
dastanden ungelogen einfach drei leute
um den roman habe auf ihn geschlagen in
der grace period deshalb wirklich doof
also habe ich auch anstalten anstatt
loszulaufen und sich christen sind ja
finde ich echt dumm ich mein was bringt
es einen max zu drücken
max ist so ein lieber mensch sagte sehe
keinen grund ihn zu kühlen
das lässt auch süßen schön vielleicht
nicht was wenn ein nein nein ich muss an
meinem zweiten gamestage arbeiten ich
habe nur 2 2 aka d3 noch was ich habe 32
nein aber genau wie genau die
gewünschten hoffe du der grinsen
juni acht positionen im ranking man hat
ein bisschen 108 die haben halt nicht
und ob du bist abgestürzt wir können
nicht mal wir können glücklich bin ich
abgestürzt weil ich war nie darüber
hier ist ein team dessen team das mich
vor dem alter war das klapprad ich muss
schon wieder sterben
ich will wieder voll ausgeprägt hat er
gott da habe ich meinen kopf schon
inkludiert für den verdient
was wirst du dir verdienen hast du
vielleicht mal eine jazzband für mich
oder so selbst nicht verdienen bis ein
hässlicher alter weiße ich habe keine
rüstung kommt sie auf die idee mit den
chefs plätze geben oder jetzt schon hast
du bogen und pfeile aber jetzt schon du
bist besser damit ich hab ich keine
nicht alles so dass man hier ein
bisschen die stark ist durchschauen
es passierte nichts mehr nein übersehen
wurde wie die hier zum beispiel mit
kuchen
ja ich kann mir einen schritt machen
wiesen schwerste diaz überhaupt nicht
also ich weiß nicht ich sondern viel
lieber mit alten schwert mit mit der axt
mit einer bis auf einen
ich habe aber eine richtig schlechte
rüstung
die ist wirklich nicht gut aber ich weiß
nicht recht ist kann sie die beste idee
die aber ihr seid eure musik in die
kommentare
ja ist ein alter wichtig stable
hier kann nichts machen desto leiser
wenn ich hab mal weg ist okay ich hab
meine auch gekillt sehr gut so perfekt
ist perfekt ich meine bei team kann viel
schief gelaufen
aber man so macht jeder schnappt sich
ein gebt ihm dann ist eigentlich
traumhaft hatte der dfb-chef
so muss das neue haben bist bist du voll
ein nein bei weitem nicht
aber okay da was ich verzeichnet ja du
hast einen die schwerter ja wir manchmal
verketten schwert höher ist es gibt so
konnte ich werd ich weiß jetzt echt kein
okay ich habe sechs punkte aber jetzt
super turnier gespielt
ich habe oft ging also ich nehmen dürfen
wir in tritt was sind du hast dir wer du
bist einfach zu hause
nein hat mit ihr schwert also ist ein
einschnitt aber egal bringt nichts dann
in dem die eisenstädter ich habe hart
getroffen ich habe es gerade unter
geworfen
ich gehe dann geht der brand ist ein
fairer bei dieser kran ii muss man klar
sagen und ich würde sagen wem 32 kein
gold abo kein gold apfel
ach du bist doch ein wachstum ohne waffe
ich denke das ok 321 co
yabo spam bots bremer grandiosen jahres
und bauleiter
es ist einfach für mich ist einfach
leicht reden weil so ein bisschen okay
jetzt kriegst du auch deine schnauze
hochnäsige zicke weiter weil es knapp 14
meter wo mein telefon klingt okay leute
mein telefon ging wir sehen uns dann die
nächste folge wieder geht eine positive
wertung schreibt einen kommentar und
titania bei der beschreibung zschau